this episode was sponsored by kiwiko
more about them at the end of the show
until recently half the universe was
missing
or hidden or just undetected and no i'm
not talking about dark matter or dark
energy which make up
27 and 68 percent of our universe
respectively
no i'm talking about normal ordinary
matter which makes up
you and me and the planets and stars and
nebulae and basically
everything you can see and since most of
this stuff is made of protons and
neutrons which are forms of
baryons this has been known as the
missing baryon problem
we expect the universe to be made up of
five percent baryonic matter
but when we go looking we only find two
and a half percent
now the first question you're probably
asking is why should we expect the
universe to be five percent
ordinary baryonic matter in the first
place
the answer is because with that density
we can explain the relative abundances
of different elements that we observe in
the universe
specifically the ratio of deuterium to
hydrogen to helium
in the beginning like right after the
big bang
there were all of these neutrons and
protons whizzing around it was
incredibly hot and there was tons of
radiation the universe was
radiation dominated but as the universe
expanded
it cooled to the point where protons and
neutrons
could start fusing together a
particularly stable nucleus to form
would be helium-4 made of two neutrons
and two protons
the problem was to form helium-4 you
first have to form
deuterium one proton and one neutron and
this is a less stable nucleus and as
quickly as it formed
it would get smashed apart but by about
10 seconds after the big bang
the universe had cooled sufficiently
that deuterium
could form and as soon as it did it
would rapidly fuse
into helium the rate at which this
happened depended on the density of
matter in the early universe
the higher the density the faster this
fusion could occur
then by 20 minutes after the big bang
the temperature had dropped
low enough that fusion could no longer
occur
so at this point the elemental
abundances were locked in
like a snapshot of this moment there was
75
hydrogen and 25 helium by mass which
is basically still what we observe in
the universe today
of the hydrogen nuclei 26 out of every
million
were deuterium
what's amazing about deuterium is that
it's stable
it doesn't decay and there are no known
processes that can produce it in
significant quantities
since the big bang and that means
virtually all the deuterium in the
universe today
including the one out of every 6 000
hydrogen atoms in tap water
was created not in stars but in
the first 20 minutes after the big bang
when we look deep into space the oldest
light we can see
is the cosmic microwave background
radiation the
afterglow of the big bang which has been
traveling
through the universe unimpeded since
about 400
000 years after the big bang and so we
can literally
count up those photons and work out the
density of radiation
right after the big bang and using the
value of 26 deuterium nuclei
per million hydrogen nuclei well we
can work out the ratio of baryonic
matter to photons
and that is how we work out that there
should be about five percent
baryonic matter in the universe so in
the late 1990s
scientists went looking for all this
baryonic matter
it was a census of sorts they added up
all of the planets and stars and black
holes
galaxies dust clouds gas basically
everything you can see or infer exists
using a telescope
and what they found is that everything
that i normally think of as the actual
stuff in our universe it only makes up
barely 20 percent of all the baryonic
matter
so where is the rest well
not all ordinary matter is glowing
brightly or is illuminated by nearby
stars
it's not dark matter but it is ordinary
matter
that is just in darkness and so if you
want to find
those baryons well one way is to use a
backlight
a bright source of light very far away
and that also means in the very early
universe
and quasars are the perfect backlight
their luminosity can be thousands of
times that of whole
galaxies the light comes from the
accretion disk of a supermassive black
hole
at the center of an early galaxy as it
engulfs
all this matter and since it is so
distant
the light we receive from quasars is
heavily redshifted
for example the light emitted when a
hydrogen atom goes from its first
excited state to its ground state the
lyman alpha transition
it produces ultraviolet light of around
121.6 nanometers in a lab
but from a quasar it can be observed as
a peak
in their spectrum at over 560 nanometers
that is yellow light what's fascinating
is if you look to the left of this peak
you see many
little dips these are absorption lines
created by
neutral hydrogen atoms that lie along
our line of sight with the quasar
when light from the quasar reaches
neutral hydrogen
the photons that can excite the
electrons from the ground state to the
first excited state
are absorbed this is the same lyman
alpha transition
but since these patches of hydrogen gas
are closer to us
they are less red-shifted so the notches
they make in the spectrum
are at shorter and shorter wavelengths
the closer the gas is
to us this has been described
as the lyman alpha forest
it's like a one-dimensional map that
shows us
where and how much neutral hydrogen gas
lies along the line connecting us to the
quasar
adding all of that neutral hydrogen gas
into our baryon budget brings us
almost to 50 percent so where
is the other half of the baryons well
computer simulations of the entire
universe
suggested they are out there just in
between the galaxies
in these sheets or filaments and they're
very spread out just
one to ten particles per cubic meter
plus these particles are ionized so they
don't absorb the light
like the neutral hydrogen gas and
they're in a temperature range
between about 100 000 and 10 million
kelvin
a range astronomers like to refer to as
warm hot
so this is known as the warm hot
intergalactic medium or
whim for short but finding the whim
has been a real challenge because
they're ionized because of their
temperature they only
emit or absorb in the high energy uv or
low energy x-rays now some people have
used
very sophisticated techniques to try to
find the whim
but then recently a naturally occurring
physical phenomenon
allowed us to find all of the missing
baryons
let's find out how first we need to talk
lightning and i promise this is related
okay so did you know that it's possible
to detect lightning from the other side
of the earth this is because lightning
produces a
flash of electromagnetic radiation in
all parts of the spectrum
i mean we see the white light but
there's also broad spectrum
radio waves which are released and if
you were nearby you could detect those
as
a pulse but the very low frequency radio
waves can actually travel
up and out of the atmosphere and they
get guided along the earth's magnetic
field lines
out several radii from the earth and
then back down
where they can be detected in the other
hemisphere except
if they're detected there they don't
come in as a single pulse
instead they are spread out as a
whistler
now if you play these radio waves
through a speaker we can actually hear
them so
listen to this
[Music]
you hear that descending tone that
sounds like a
sci-fi laser gun yeah that is lightning
on the other side
of the earth so what's happening here
well as the radio waves travel through
the earth's magnetosphere
they encounter free electrons which
slows them down
and more for the lower frequency waves
this is dispersion just as a prism
separates white light into its component
colors
the plasma in the magnetosphere
separates the radio waves
into its component frequencies low
frequencies are slowed down more than
high frequencies
so what started as a pulse ends up as a
whistler
and the amount of dispersion tells you
how many free electrons that radio wave
had to pass through to reach the
detector now just imagine
we could do something very similar to
find all the ionized baryons in the
universe
all we would need is a bright flash
of radio waves somewhere in the distant
universe
and as if on cue in 2007 astronomers
found the first
fast radio burst which is just what it
sounds like a very
short duration pulse of intense
radio waves and it came from the deep
universe from other galaxies now these
pulses can be
incredibly powerful i'm talking billions
or trillions of times as powerful as the
sun but they last
for on order of a millisecond we don't
really know what creates them though
some people suspect that it's magnetars
or
neutron stars or some sort of collision
between
these very powerful massive objects like
black holes and
neutron stars but for our purposes
all we need to know is that those
flashes exist
and that we can use them to look at
their dispersion and figure out
how many ionized baryons are between us
and the source
and this is exactly what one recent
paper did in
nature they plotted out the dispersion
measure of
several of these fast radio bursts
versus the redshift of their host
galaxy and what they found was sure
enough
the further out these fast radio bursts
were the more dispersed
their signal when it reached the earth
and in fact using their measurements
they were able to estimate the
total baryonic matter that is out there
and that includes all the ionized
particles in the whim
and they found that it was five percent
they found the missing baryons roughly
50 percent of them
are in that warm hot intergalactic
medium
and so this validates what we had been
thinking the whole time
you know what surprised me in making
this video was realizing
just how little of the ordinary matter
from the big bang ended up in things
like stars and galaxies what i normally
consider
as the stuff of the universe no that's
only like 10 or 20 percent of all the
baryonic matter
so it turns out the formation of these
interesting structures
is a really inefficient process but this
finding is
yet another triumph for science those
computer simulations run decades ago
turned out largely
to be correct and so everyone involved
should be congratulated
but this also highlights for me the
difference between scientists and
non-scientists
i feel like non-scientists like being
right they like
when things turn out the way they were
expecting but scientists on the other
hand
they want things to work out not the way
they expected
because that's the way we get clues into
what new physics
is still out there to be discovered i
guess for now we'll have to be content
with being right
hey this video was sponsored by kiwiko
which i'm really
excited about because i've been using
their monthly crates since the beginning
of the year with my four-year-old he got
it as a christmas present
and i've got to say they have been a
great resource for learning at home
each crate has super cool hands-on
projects that are fun to make and
they expose kids to steam concepts
that's science technology
engineering art and math now each box
includes all the supplies needed meaning
no extra trips to the store and kiwi co
offers
eight subscription lines for different
age groups and topics
they sent me some of the older age group
crates to try out and i had a lot of fun
uh making this this is a planetarium and
something you might not know is kiwico
is not only a subscription service you
can browse their store and purchase
individual projects or value packs for
different ages
no subscription required so let's talk
about why kiwico is so useful right now
i mean anyone who has been at home with
kids over the past few months
knows just how important it is to get
them engaged in something other than
a screen the summer brain drain happens
every year but
it is especially challenging right now
with disruptions to school and
online learning just not being as good
as you know in in-person hands-on
learning
now what i know from my own experience
is my son loves making kiwico projects
with me
he has a lot of fun and doesn't even
realize he's learning what do you see
you know one day we will talk about the
missing baryons but for right now these
projects
are a great way for us to connect and
learn together so if you want to try it
out you can get 20
off everything in the kiwi coast store
using code veritasium
or go to kiwico.com veritasium i'll put
that link in the description
so i really want to thank kiwiko for
supporting me and i want to thank you
for watching